[Musique]
[Rires]
ça s'appelle une coupe à la garçonne
mais qui quand même une point de vue du
tarif est un pari scoop femmes
ah oui c'est une inégalité quand même
assez effrayant qu'il n'y a pas plus de
temps que mon mari pour faire la
coiffure me couper les cheveux mais par
contre je paye beaucoup plus cher à
chaque fois mais vous avez eu les
cheveux beaucoup plus long j'ai eu car
évidemment on passe pas tout de suite
et puis après mais à 25 ans j'avais déjà
cette coupe donc ne pas trop changer
je trouve que c'est à d'abord rejoint
sans doute indique une forme de
stabilité politique sur le fond et puis
ce soit pas ça le sujet de commentaires
en fait les petites briques et monster
ouais d'accord sera bien là la tenue du
yoga ou été musique venant non pas
forcément pas forcément non le matin
même si je juge que vous allez voir
c'est pas du tout et au geek c'est que
il m'arrive de faire des trucs de
renforcement en écoutant même france
inter 16 mai donc on n'est plus dans le
truc un peu de gym en fait oui voilà
maintenant le soir par contre le soir
toujours évidemment dans le silence et
silence et vous terminez par une petite
méditation plus ou moins ça dépend des
fois il ya eu des cours de méditation à
l'assemblée les séances avec plein de
députés etc
ben c'est pas trop mal pour les députés
1 parce que quand même on a des vies
assez stressante extrêmement dit voilà
voilà et donc pour se recentrer
ce calme et posé sa voix
[Musique]
d'autres fois on me dit c'est karine
viard il ya un petit air regarde voilà
une autre forme a dit vous êtes cécile
de france l'a plusieurs fois l'air si je
vous propose un rôle dans un film non
[Musique]
on